the location of the zaparesia plant
makes it strategically critical to both
sides it's the closest power plant to
the parts of Ukraine annexed by Russia
east of the NEPA River and to the South
Moscow needs that electricity to control
its territory on the other side Ukraine
can't afford to lose a plant capable of
supplying 20 of its electricity but from
a safety point of view this nucleus
stalemate is perilous zaparesia is the
largest nuclear power plant in Europe it
consists of six pressurized water
reactors connected to the power grid by
four lines to a high voltage substation
and one backup linking it to a nearby
coal plant more than 2 000 tons of
Highly radioactive spent nuclear fuel is
held in storage ponds and a dry store on
the site following repeated incidents
all six reactors have been shot down
grid connections to the plant have been
regularly damaged by fires linked to
mines or shelling projectiles have also
pierced buildings immediately adjacent
to the reactors and themselves
once shot down the reactors are a much
more safe state but the fuel in them and
in storage ponds still needs cooling
water if Maine's power is lost as it was
following a recent shelling incident
only backup diesel generators can pump
water to prevent a meltdown a direct hit
to a reactor or to a storage Pond could
also cause significant if localized
nuclear contamination in a worst case
scenario a loss of power plus damage to
the reactors or Safety Systems could
result in the worst nuclear accident in
more than a decade
there is hope negotiations in Moscow can
advance an end to fighting around the
plant but with neither side willing to
relinquish control the area remains an
accident waiting to happen